Paolo vonchuli Works a long day it's
late in the night by the time he returns
to the port of telemorne in his fishing
boat but Paulo does more than fish he's
also fighting illegal catch methods
particularly the use of troll Nets just
above the seabed his battle has made him
lots of enemies
[Music]
the illegal Fishers hate me they've
tried to intimidate me I've gotten death
threats I've been banned from all the
fish markets and the worst part is that
instead of protecting me the authorities
have threatened me too
foreign
sculptures are at the root of the
conflict
Paulo dropped them there to save fish
stocks and corals
his method has proven effective because
illegal fish's expensive troll Nets get
tangled on the sculptures and tear
the illegal Fishers don't like me at all
the big players don't want me to sink
these blocks of marble these artworks in
the sea because they can't fish anymore
but they're required to fish five
kilometers from the coast and the blocks
are only 500 meters from the shore
Paolo has been working the Seas since he
was 15. he's seen how industrial fishing
has got bigger and bigger in his
homeland meanwhile the fish stops have
got smaller and smaller at some point he
started catching far fewer fish
it started looking like Paulo and other
small fishes might not catch enough to
survive
D
traditional fishing means the next day
above the seabed without destroying the
ecosystem
during industrial fishing they dropped
trawl Nets onto the seafloor they're
pulled with chains that weigh tons that
wrecks everything it's as if a hunter
would burn down an entire Forest just to
kill wild boar
foreign
to protect the sea and still pursue his
passion Paolo launched fishing tourism
he takes Travelers on his fishing boat
and wins them over to his cause
on each Voyage he tells of his opponents
[Music]
the illegal Fishers don't even stop at
Marine protected areas
he also tells his guests of how a quarry
owner once gave him 100 blocks of marble
[Music]
and how artists from all over the world
use them to make sculptures each
weighing several tons
he also recounts how he overcame
bureaucratic hurdles and recalls the
boat he used to bring the sculptures out
to sea and place them on the seabed
that marked the birth of Casa de peshi
House of fish an underwater Sculpture
Park fish stocks here have already
recovered because the fish can again
find safe places to spawn
[Music]
the aim of our work is to protect the
sea and restore what humans have
destroyed
Paulo says consumers have something to
contribute as well
it's like I always say we'll save the
environment at our own tables because if
we keep eating fish that are cut
industrially or farmed using hormones
then the illegal fissures will never
change their catch methods
they'll just keep on producing and
fishing using a system that is no longer
sustainable
[ __ ]
Paolo's strategy has had another
consequence too
the Dolphins have returned because they
find lots of fish here they know that
there's food for them along the coast
but the ongoing battle against illegal
fishing has been grueling for Paulo
I often feel sad and disappointed but
then when I'm with the guests who come
on my boat I get the strength to say you
have to keep on going
so Paulo fanchuli sets off again each
morning to save his sea
[Music]